we've been talking about it now for
weeks the Oakland A's moving right here
to Las Vegas well now it's Bally's right
who announced a binding agreement with
the A's to take over the site of the
Tropicana Hotel they're in a very
preliminary stages right now of that
deal but Tropicana employees already
gearing up for what's to come eight news
now reporter Madison Kimbrough live in
studio tonight with what the county and
local employees are saying yeah we spoke
to several Tropicana employees who
because of their circumstances didn't
feel comfortable being on camera however
many say they welcome this change but
aren't too concerned for their jobs
until everything is finalized
if it's related to the A's we'll see it
when they're ready to give it to us
discussions going back and forth on
where the A's stadium will end up ever
since reports broke that the major
league baseball team is planning to make
Las Vegas their new home
now all eyes are on the Tropicana Hotel
Site after Bally's entered a binding
agreement with the A's it's a location
County Commissioner Jim Gibson overseas
people are excited who want to see
baseball here they'd like to have this
come to an end and let's get about the
business of funding and building a
stadium but while nothing has been
finalized Bally's Corporation stating
that they are in preliminary stages of
the deal and those who work at the
Tropicana Hotel already preparing for
what's to come
[Music]
classic r b Duo Cool Change has been
performing at the Tropicana for over 10
years they tell us they'll miss doing
shows there but mostly feel for the
full-time employees who invested decades
working there but I really feel bad for
the workers even though it's 18 months
to 24 months when you're in a job you
just used to being there so getting out
looking for a job you know you look up
and those 18 months will go by just like
that I sing play a little bit of
keyboard I work with Randy and we've
been here for a bunch of years we like
playing here so I don't know where we're
going to go from here
and in a statement obtained by eight
news Now by The Culinary Union their
secretary treasurer says quote Culinary
Union members at the Tropicana Casino
have a strong Union contract which means
that Tropicana workers are protected The
Culinary Union will negotiate to ensure
workers rights under the contract that
are strictly followed while the property
is closed for development again Bally's
Corporation not confirming just yet if
the hotel will in fact close for a
ballpark to then be built in studio
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now